pero claramente mucha gente pensaba que
el presidente intentaría de anular
digamos los resultados de las elecciones
de noviembre por la vía legal o sea los
tribunales por ejemplo sea por ejemplo
las opciones de los congresistas que se
estaban discutiendo hoy en día por la
tarde pero en realidad
pensó también a un verdadero golpe un
golpe físico una invasión del capitolio
lo hizo exactamente cuando los
congresistas estaban decidiendo y
discutiendo la aprobación de la elección
de sus resultados me parece muy
interesante y extraño que no hubo una
defensa del edificio porque para entrar
en el capítulo de los eeuu
hoy en día uno tiene que pasar para
medidas muy estrictas de seguridad en la
policía del capitolio tiene la
reputación de ser muy agresiva hemos
visto hoy una ausencia total de la
policía defendiendo las entradas al
edificio e interviniendo cuando era
demasiado tarde aún no han solucionado
la situación lo que me parece raro
parece casi que tenemos nosotros también
de participar en estas teorías de la
conspiración pero es raro ver esto en
una ciudad como boeing donde
particularmente en el capítulo cuando
todos los diputados y todos los
senadores
están en el edificio un momento muy
difícil muy dramático muy peligroso
así que trump claramente quería un golpe
de estado un golpe de estado en el
forzar a los congresistas de no
continuar su aprobación de los
resultados de las elecciones y de crear
una crisis enorme constitucional en el
país lo que podría aún pasar es un
momento muy difícil para los eeuu se
demuestra también la fragilidad de la
democracia cuando damos tantos poder a
un líder que verdaderamente no piensa al
país a la patria que piensa a sí mismo a
su propio poder
este llamado que realizó donald trump
hoy a sus manifestantes para que vayan
al congreso considera usted entonces que
fue algo deliberado no premeditado para
que suceda esto que está ocurriendo
ahora
claro que sí por eso que él llamó este
ese mitin por eso que él invitó a sus
seguidores de llegar miles a washington
y él sabía muy bien que entre ellos hay
gente muy violenta como pro voice los
chicos orgullosos como los llaman que ya
hicieron destrozos quemaron banderas y
aceptaron la iglesia afroamericanos aquí
en la ciudad de washington hace
solamente unos días y claramente él lo
había planeado el planeado muy bien si
yo tengo miles de personas que me apoyan
no lo hago enfurecerse que se enfurezcan
durante mi discurso lo que les instó de
ir al capitolio defenderme a donde hay
todos los congresistas senadores y
diputados claramente no lo hizo a
propósito para que no se pudiese
continuar la discusión y hoy confirmar
finalmente definitivamente la elección
del debate lo hizo a propósito y casi
tuvo éxito
y estoy hablando de que raro que no hubo
una defensa del edificio que pudieron
entrar por muchas de las entradas y
caminar y irse por el edificio donde
había todos los legisladores federales
del país esto me parece algo que es muy
curioso y por eso que no había una buena
presencia de policía ni de la ciudad me
del capitolio ni la guardia nacional que
llamaron para estar lista intervenir no
había ninguna línea de defensa me parece
algo muy interesante en este sentido
vemos más y más como el trump se está
transformando en un peligro para los
eeuu porque él dice si yo tengo que ir
me voy a irme destruyendo todo es casi
como si usted invita a alguien que está
en su casa y finalmente irse porque por
qué no no se comportan bien no pagan su
alquiler lo que sea destruyen todo antes
de irse de salir de la casa es es lo que
él está haciendo cada día destruyendo y
estudiando también acuerdos
internacionales causando crisis
internacionales y de todo para que el
baile no pueda asumir la presidencia o
si la asume que tenga problemas enormes
para poder empezar a funcionar como
debería
será muy en poder
verdaderamente gobernar lo que hace el
país vulnerable ataques reales
cibernéticos lo que sea durante mucho
tiempo
señor piano usted plantea esta sospecha
respecto del accionar de las fuerzas de
seguridad por la facilidad con la que le
resultó a los manifestantes que apoyan a
donald trump llegará hasta el congreso e
incluso ingresar a las instalaciones que
hipótesis le dispara esto usted estas
son las o no cierta convivencia quizás
entre las fuerzas de seguridad y el
tropismo
bueno podría ser no tengo ninguna
información oficial
pero no lo encuentro muy raro porque
vivo aquí en washington es lo sé muy
bien que por entrar en el capitolio hay
medidas de seguridad muy muy severas en
la policía del capitolio tiene una
reputación de ser una policía bastante
agresiva y mismo si usted pasa por ahí
todos los días de día de noche hay
policías en todas las avenidas que
llegan al capitolio para examinar los
coches que llegan para que no lleguen
coches que podrían ser peligrosos como
un camión por algo así y de repente hay
nadie que defiende el edificio cuando
hay 100 senadores y 435 más o menos
diputados en el edificio están
discutiendo en la elección los
resultados y al final se esperaba porque
no hay otra salida declaraba en el
presidente y me parece que hay algo ahí
que tal vez vamos a descubrir en el
futuro próximo puede ser porque aún
ahora como ustedes pueden ver por sus
imágenes esta gente está ahí tranquila
no no hay ninguna intervención para
desalojarlos lo que si fuese una
situación normal pasaría muy veloz al
gas lacrimógeno hay mucha policía en la
ciudad están están impidiendo un
edificio a donde no tienen derecho de
entrar particularmente cuando hay
reuniones del congreso e interesante muy
raro y yo creo que se hablará de esto
bastante en el futuro próximo
asistimos a imágenes impactantes en
estos momentos que llegan en vivo desde
washington eeuu con miles de
simpatizantes del presidente de donald
trump con el mando el congreso
estadounidense y habiendo ingresado en
las instalaciones todo esto para
rechazar e impedir que el demócrata joe
biden sea confirmado como presidente
electo del país y estamos en
comunicación con emilio viano analista
político en medio y esto viene atrás
una suerte de varios enfrentamientos
entre el presidente de donald trump o
quizás más que enfrentamiento grietas y
tensiones no con representantes y
líderes de su partido uno de los últimos
y más claves tiene que ver con mike
pence no su vicepresidente quien
contrario a lo que le pidió donald trump
y que para lo que para algunos fue una
suerte de amenazas o la paga no él se
negaba a no declarar a joe biden como
presidente electo algo que le pedía a
donald trump considera usted que también
venimos de varios otras tensiones no
como por ejemplo los republicanos
anulando el veto de donald trump para la
ley el presupuesto de defensa considera
que donald trump quizás está apelando
mucho más a sus seguidores en este
contexto de grieta al interior de su
partido dado que no consigue se hace el
apoyo de los integrantes del movimiento
republicano muy bien dicho
trump quiere demostrar mismo a los
republicanos que tiene un gran poder
y gran poder a nivel nacional que puede
animar a miles y miles de personas de
llegar a washington de impedir el
capitolio de demostrar con la fuerza
mismo quién sabe de tener armas y bombas
con ellos vale decir él quiere demostrar
que él tiene el poder una comunicación
directa con el pueblo al mínimo el 50
por ciento de los votantes digamos más o
menos y que puede influir también sobre
las carreras en las legislativas la
carrera de congresistas que están en
este edificio para decir que usted
quiere en el futuro el año próximo 2022
elecciones del congreso cámara diputados
particularmente 2024 otra elección
presidencial si usted quiere tener tener
éxito
para empezar usted tiene que estar a mi
lado porque yo puedo una declaración con
un tuit totalmente destruir su carrera
su futuro su reelección y agregarlo a
regresar a su casa y encontrar otro
empleo esto es lo que quiere de
manifestar claramente en el yo tengo
poder ustedes tienen que escucharme y
ustedes tienen que protegerme así que yo
puedo continuar
otros cuatro años si no yo voy a
destruir su carrera su futuro puedo
porque pueden ver cuánta gente me apoya
y con un tuit lo puedo hacer aún es
noticia y además el amenaza también de
crear problemas para el país para la
política internacional para las
intervenciones militares de los eeuu
para el futuro del país mismo
está tomando muchas decisiones al nivel
ejecutivo para derribar reglas leyes
políticas que protegen el país desde el
aire limpio digamos al tipo de aviones
que podemos utilizar en el juego en los
vuelos para decir que él intenta de
verdaderamente crear como una
destrucción dejar detrás de él ruinas
para que paraguay de sea muy difícil
gobernar si al final puede tomar la
presidencia
hablando precisamente del señor ya no de
estas divisiones no de estas grietas al
interior del partido republicano
considera usted que atrás de estos
cuatro años de mandato donald trump
logró
digamos lo que no se había logrado hasta
el momento crear una fuerza que se
encuentra incluso a la derecha del
partido republicano una suerte de trump
ismo claro no hay más el partido
republicano que existía antes es mi
partido de trump y claramente el as
tiene un apoyo apabullante de digamos el
40 por ciento cincuenta por ciento de
los votantes como hemos visto en las
últimas elecciones presidenciales
tenemos que admitir que hubo un apoyo
muy fuerte para él aunque perdió lo que
demuestra que hay gente también que
piensa hay que decir de que trump no es
una buena noticia para el país cuatro
años más de todo esto de todo este
desorden cambios continuos divisiones
críticas insultos lo que sea
y él sabe muy bien que tiene el apoyo de
mucha gente y que los republicanos que
quieren tener una carrera tienen que
estar a su lado tiene que adular lo
tienen que proteger lo tiene que
intervenir aunque sea en contra de la
ley para que él pueda continuar y hay
razones diferentes una por ejemplo de
pintarse como una víctima después de las
elecciones de noviembre porque porque
primero obtiene toda la simpatía
compasión apoyo empobrecimiento de los
que son sus seguidores más cercanos
segundo él ha recaudado centenares de
millones de fondos se está hablando de
casi 300 millones de fondos que recibió
desde noviembre de este año para por sí
mismo a donde tiene muy pocas reglas de
la ley de cómo gastarlos así que esto
también le da poder porque se un
republicano quiere presentarse para uno
una elección trump si este republicano
está a su lado le puede dar dinero le
puede financiar su campaña puede influir
sobre cómo es percibido por ejemplo y
además puede utilizarlo para sí mismo
más que todo no quiere salir de la casa
blanca también porque se enfrenta con
muchas investigaciones que podrían
resultar en una persecución penal en
donde no tiene protección en el sentido
que hay dos niveles de poder en los
estados unidos dos soberanías la
soberanía federal la soberanía de los 50
estados
los la ciudad de washington distrito de
colombia bueno al nivel federal
trump ya ha perdonado a muchísima gente
que lo ha apoyado a veces mintiendo y no
colaborando con la justicia se está
hablando que él podría perdonar a sí
mismo esto no me es tan claro que puede
ser así que a los que dicen que
probablemente un par de días antes
que vayan tómense la presidencia podría
renunciar dar la presidencia al
vicepresidente pensé que después lo
perdonaría así que sería un perdón
válido no voy a perdonar a sí mismo es
ser perdonado por el presidente en
funciones de serie pensé vamos a ver qué
pasa allí pero él preferiría quedarse en
la casa blanca porque porque le ofrece
la protección de la ley no se puede
denunciar a un presidente en función
esta es la doctrina que han adoptado
aquí en un es una ley lunes en la
constitución es una opinión del
ministerio de justicia de hace años no
se puede acusar a un presidente en
función de un crimen así que él
él está adquiriendo cuatro otro años de
protección y como usted sabe en el
derecho penal el concepto de
prescripción que significa es que si uno
comete un crimen por el acusado de un
crimen
digamos hoy si puede evitar
en la persecución penal digamos por diez
años pasados los diez años ya no se
puede hacer nada contra de él se llama
prescripción no y trump está está
mirando el reloj y dice ah sí yo tengo
cuatro años más
cuántas cuántas acusaciones serán nulas
inválidas porque ya entró en función la
prescripción así que hay muchas
motivaciones para él en su desesperación
de no salir muchos se enfocan sobre que
no quiere ser un perdedor que perdió
puede ser claro puede ser una una
función psicológica suba pero hay mucho
más astuto mucho más cínico de todo esto
segundo recaudó fondos pidiéndole ayuda
a la protección en sus seguidores
hablando de ser la víctima de un complot
que debería ser develado tercero evitar
la persecución penal al nivel de estado
por ejemplo el estado de nueva york que
no está investigando para muchas
posibilidades y acusas criminales
en el campo de impuestos en el campo de
operaciones financieras etcétera así que
hay muchos muchos muchas razones por las
cuales él está desesperadamente
intentando de sabotear
este cambio de presidente